- Still to this day,
I don't believe he beat it.
- You still don't think
he ran a 4.22?
Simms Schefter over here got all the scoop
on Antonio Brown.
Derek Carr and Odell Beckham Jr.
and Jon Gruden on your team?
- Wow.
- That'll sell tickets in Vegas in a hurry.
♪♪♪
- Wild Card playoffs, we made it!
- We made it, baby!
- Seventeen weeks and it's the playoffs!
The regular season starts now! But guess what?
- For the New England Patriots.
- Yeah.
- It's their regular season.
- Man.
We're gonna get to all the teams later in the show.
Allie, helping us figure out Chicago and Philadelphia.
We check in with Chris Johnson–
- Right.
- Our good buddy.
- CJ2K!
- But two teams that aren't even in the playoffs,
their wide receivers have taken over the news cycle.
- Yeah.
- First, Simms Schefter over here got all the scoop
on Antonio Brown and the Pittsburgh Steelers.
- Right.
- It sounds like a mess.
- It does sound like a mess.
I don't think there's any doubt about that.
- And you got some scoop.
- I do have scoop.
Talking to players, ex-players, other
people that work in the organization,
I've gotten the story from a number
of people. And I think the one thing–
- Yeah, what did you take away from all this?
- The biggest thing is that Antonio Brown
has had dysfunctional issues
within that organization for a while, whether it's being
late for meetings, or little things that we saw this week.
- Like, always late for meetings?
- Habitual. This is a habitual thing, right.
- We've said this as people have
crucified Odell over the years that Antonio,
from the Gatorade smashing, to the
Facebook Lives, to the insulting the reporter,
threatening the reporter–
- To furniture off the balcony.
- Right, it's been constant.
- It has been constant, and–
- So we're not shocked.
- No, we're not shocked. We have
heard all of these stories.
I think what's shocking, last week,
and it was such a big game.
They're playing to get into the playoffs,
hopefully, against the Cincinnati Bengals.
There's a disagreement during
a walkthrough on Wednesday.
Antonio Brown felt disrespected about it.
He didn't show up for at least two to three days.
- Just didn't show up?
- Didn't show up at all. And then came to
the locker room on Sunday expecting to play,
and of course, they did not let him do that.
And then he went out there, and you saw him in his mink coat.
And he's the man, don't get me wrong, he's a baller supreme.
- Yes.
- But he did, yes. I was told he left at halftime.
- Your big point is, whenever something happens on the Steelers,
we point a finger at Mike Tomlin and say he has no control.
- Right.
- And you're saying, "Exactly. He has no control."
- Thank you.
- "So why are we blaming Tomlin?"
- Exactly right. I don't like that Mike Tomlin
gets the blame for all of these things when, you know,
he's not the center focus of who drafted some of these players
or negotiating their contracts, or negotiating to the
point where there's so much dead money right now.
Then people go, "Well, they're gonna trade Antonio Brown."
No, they're not. They can't trade Antonio Brown.
If they trade him or cut him, they are
gonna be on the hook for $21 million.
That's like three or four quality
starting players on your roster.
- Might as well keep him and try to win with him.
- Exactly right, and deal with him.
You've been dealing with him already anyway.
- In comparison, Odell seems like a choir boy.
- [Laughing] Yeah.
- And a lot of people have been saying,
including you, they're gonna trade him.
You don't got a quarterback that can
reach him. It doesn't make sense.
Gettleman has come out and says,
"We're not gonna trade him."
- Right.
- But you don't say–
- Well, it's early in the offseason. Ehh, I gotta see it to believe it there.
- Yeah.
- I mean, yeah, I just think there's some things, you know,
reading the tea leaves or between the lines, right, of just what we've seen.
First of all, I think in the Mara family, who's close to the
Rooney family in Pittsburgh, and they're probably goin',
"Hmm, do we really want this issue to happen to us
two or three years down the road with Odell Beckham Jr. maybe?"
- Interesting.
- To me, just thinking as a football person,
and I know there'll be a demand for him,
and then a lot of his money's been paid already.
So then teams are gonna go,
"Ooh, well that's not so bad to trade for him."
I'm just saying, it's a possibility.
- Let's open up the Simms Chaos Generator.
- Oh, gosh.
- I'm gonna turn this wheel, and we're gonna
put out four teams that Odell could possibly go to.
- Sure.
- We're gonna start off in Indianapolis.
- Yes. Yes, the Indianapolis Colts.
They have so much money.
You have an offensive line. You got,
of course, Andrew Luck, right?
You don't– I don't think they need necessarily
to go out and get a big-time running back
cuz they got two or three in the rotation that are good already.
- Yeah.
- But you pair up an Odell Beckham Jr. with
Andrew Luck on the other side of T.Y. Hilton?
Whoo! Watch out. That is a young nucleus
that could grow together and really be special.
- I got another young quarterback for you.
- OK.
- Crank, crank, crank, crank, crank. Josh Allen.
- Ooh, I mean, that to me–
- I just wanna say that Odell in Buffalo is
not a visual that I thought I'd see.
- I get it.
- He'd be out there in a mink coat bein' like, "Y'all live in this crap?"
- [Laughing] Right.
- But Josh Allen throwing to Odell–
- I think that's where I look at it–yes, the commercial
appeal is not gonna be there about the Buffalo Bills.
But the New York Giants, if they are trading him away,
aren't gonna be worried about what his
commercial appeal is in this situation.
But I look at a team like the Buffalo Bills–
have a lot of money, assets and then a quarterback
and then a quarterback who has an arm like
Patrick Mahomes and big-time talent that we saw.
- We'll see where it all ends up, but there's
no weapons there to support him right now,
and I'm just sayin', that's one guy that could help.
- Last one.
- Bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
- Our favorite coach in the NFL.
- That's right.
- Kyle Shanahan. We thought–you thought–maybe
the Niners before the contract got done.
- Yeah. Well, I'm gonna throw another one in there with it.
I'm gonna put the Bay Area in general. The Raiders
and the 49ers, I think, would be in this conversation.
- Really?
- First of all, let's just talk about the Raiders.
Going to Vegas, and you've got Derek Carr
and Odell Beckham Jr. and Jon Gruden on your team?
- Wow.
- That'll sell tickets in Vegas in a hurry, OK?
And I just think they need the weapons,
and Jon Gruden can use him in that type of offense.
Same thing with Kyle Shanahan and the San Francisco 49ers.
I think that could make sense and certainly make a splash
for the 49ers to go, "Here we come for our playoff run in 2019."
- Le'Veon, Odell and Antonio all go to the Colts.
- [Laughing]
- And Andrew Luck has a field day in 2019!
- Throws for 75 touchdown passes.
- Incredible.
Hi, I'm Champ Bailey,
and you're watching
Simms & Lefkoe.
- Usually I do
the introductions, but I—
This is you.
This is your guy.
- This is my guy.
I mean, this is
the original CJ2K.
My man right here.
I didn't know what to expect
when I saw
this guy in person as a player.
Like—
- Cuz he was a rookie
when you were there.
- He was a rookie.
And in training camp, I was
with the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
So I—
that team, as he'll tell you
had a bunch of Texas guys
on the Tennessee Titans team.
And they kept telling me,
"Man, this Chris Johnson
is a baller, man.
We've never seen
anybody so fast."
And I was like,
"Yeah, bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh."
But then I got there and
yes, one of the most special
talents I have ever been around.
- And then, your memories
of Chris Simms back then?
- Oh, man. He used to talk trash
to me before every game.
- Stop.
- I think it was probably
like Week 2 or Week 3.
He was like, "Ah, come on"
I was—I think I had went
for 100 yards, like, twice.
He's like, "Come on, man.
I'm tired of seeing these 10-,
15-yard runs.
Break off somethin' long."
I think, that same game,
LenDale broke for 80
and I came right back
and broke for, like, 76.
- Kansas City.
- Kansas City game.
He did.
- I feel like that's when the
Smash and Dash thing took off.
- Right. It did.
- When those two big
runs happened.
- Yeah.
- Yep.
- I think that's
a nickname that I feel like
they try to give
to a lot of duos now.
But you guys
were Smash and Dash.
- Yeah, yeah, we started that.
They asked us, like,
what was our name.
-Yes.
- And LenDale was like,
"We Smash and Dash."
- Right.
- He came up with Smash and Dash
and then ever since then
they just started
calling us that every week.
- Smash and Dash, OK
him and LenDale,
I mean, characters
and LenDale
especially a character.
- That's an all-time
running back room.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
And LenDale—
we can put him on blast now
cuz his career is over—
- [Laughing]
- He was late a lot, OK?
I mean, late a lot.
- Right.
- Like, and always had
a different excuse.
Creative as hell, right?
- How much is "late"?
- Yeah, see? He knows it's true.
Like, if we had an 8:30 meeting
LenDale was, I felt like,
never there at 8:30.
Never.
- And this is every day?
- I mean, at least once
or twice a week.
- OK.
- And he'd always have
some great excuse.
I mean, great.
What do you think
his best excuse was?
What was one you remember,
you remember any good ones?
- Yeah. He was late one time,
and he came in and he was like
"Man, I had to pull over
to the gas station bathroom
and my stomach was hurting.
I had to use the bathroom."
- He was just—
So his excuse was "I took a crap
at a gas station."
- I had to take a crap
in a bathroom, yes.
- And then when he says that,
the team explodes?
- No, actually.
Cuz it's a serious setting.
- [Laughing]
- I mean, we're all shaking
our head like
"What a bunch of bullcrap
that is."
But there's nothin' we can say
cuz Jeff Fisher is still
the head coach
and he's standing
in front of the room
and we're not gonna butt
into that conversation.
So I want to ask Mr. 4.24
who's the fastest guy
in the NFL right now?
- Tyreek Hill.
- OK.
- Gotta go with Tyreek Hill.
- Is it unreal how fast he is?
- He's fast.
- I mean, like, I'm not tryin'
to disrespect you
or Joey Galloway
or Deion Sanders
but he is the fastest f--ker
I have ever seen.
- Maybe he's the second-
or the third-fastest.
I wouldn't say the fastest.
- You wouldn't say
he's the fastest?
- Not the fastest.
- I know, cuz you're gonna
take yourself.
- Of course.
- I know.
- You should.
- What was bigger,
the 2,000 or the 4.24?
- 2,000.
- Mm.
But the 4.24 we had
never seen before.
You got the watch made,
all that.
- Yeah.
- When you saw John Ross
beat the 4.24—
- Eye emoji.
That was what he sent out, as
soon as he ran the—remember?
The official time hadn't came in
and he tweeted "eye emoji,"
the big eyes.
- Was there part of you
that was like
"I hope that gets corrected
and it's actually a 4.25."
- Probably a part of me.
But still to this day,
I don't believe he beat it.
- You still don't think
he ran a 4.22?
- No.
When you look—
OK, for one, when you look
at the side-by-side
I pulled off on him
at the end.
- Right.
- That's fascinating.
- And number two is,
when has it ever took
that long for the official time
to come in?
- It did take a long time.
You're right.
- Wow.
- So you believe
that it was rigged?
Just say it.
Say it with your chest.
- They probably got tired of,
tired of—
- Showing your highlight
all the time?
- Yeah, they probably got tired
of no one beating it
and felt like the combine
was getting boring, so—
- Right.
- They needed more attention.
- Needed more attention.
- I love it.
- I'm a big
conspiracy theory guy.
This is one of the best ones
I've ever heard.
- I'm telling you.
I don't believe it.
- I have to imagine you would go
out and people would be, like
in the club goin', "I'll race
you in the parking lot."
- Yeah.
- All the time?
- All the time.
- That's just the dumbest crap ever.
- Anywhere. Everywhere.
- The dumbest crap ever.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, they don't know
what they're messin' with.
- Since you are the master
of 40 times
we have some very famous
running clips from movies
that we'd like you to watch
and tell us what you think
their "40 times" would be.
- OK.
♪♪♪
- We're gonna start off first
this is the scene
from "Get Out."
So watch my man run.
We all remember the scene.
Scares the crap out of this guy.
Running straight at him.
Turns to the left side.
- Aw, man.
- That form is phenomenal.
His elbows are in perfect spots.
[Whooshing]
- That was 4.1 right there.
- A 4.1?!
- That was a 4.1.
Look how fast he's runnin'!
- So, you're admitting that
someone may be faster than you.
- Yeah, probably him.
- Wow.
- All right, next one is
"Mission: Impossible."
It is the crazy lunatic
that is Tom Cruise.
What do you think
Tom Cruise's 40 time was
in "Mission: Impossible"?
- Yeah, that's 4.3 right there.
- 4.3?
- Yeah, that's 4.3.
- You're being generous.
He's got the d—
- The duck feet. A little bit.
Yes, right. Yeah.
I mean, he's like 4.8ish to me.
No way he's beatin' me
in a race.
- Yeah, but he's going over stairs
and everything.
He's not even slowin' down.
- Yeah, he is.
All right. Next one up.
Much better movie.
"Bad Boys."
The king that is Will Smith.
Runnin' with the gun in hand.
And then he's gotta save
Martin Lawrence.
What do you think the top
speed that Will hit there was?
- He 4.8 right there.
That's 4.8.
- Oh!
- That's 4.8.
- Real low on Will Smith.
Now to a legendary runner.
The Forrest Gump.
In the khakis.
What do you think
his top speed there was?
- He looks 4.2 right there.
- 4.2?
- At the top speed right there.
- Right there?
- Yeah, right there.
- And then the last one
is Michael Cera in "Superbad."
As he's gonna run
from the cops here—
- Ah, man. He's a 5.5.
- Ohh, you see the knees buckle
and the legs out to the side?
- Yeah. Chris,
you're faster than him.
- I know.
I definitely am.
Thank you.
- All right, so let's recap these.
You have "Get Out"
as your leader at 4.1.
Coming in second place,
"Forrest Gump" at 4.2.
Third place,
"Mission: Impossible."
Tom Cruise at 4.3.
Will Smith shockingly gets
fourth place at a 4.8.
And Michael Cera,
appropriately, 5.5.
Do you agree
with his rankings there?
- I do. I thought maybe he was a
hair nice to Tom Cruise, but—
- I agree.
- But other than that,
it's pretty good.
- "Get Out" beats "Forrest Gump."
- Yep.
- Try to avoid going
to the sunken place.
Well, good luck to you,
my friend.
- Thank you.
- It was a pleasure
talking to you.
- Thank you.
- Way to go. You did it.
It is time for the playoffs and this is where
the gamblers make their most money.
Simms is usually the Oracle this time of year
but we're not giving up hope on Allie.
And honestly, there's one Wild Card Game
more than the rest, that matters more to
me, and I need to know who Allie's taking.
7-4 on the season. Allie, congratulations.
$119.05
for picking the Cowboys over the Giants.
- Ohh, I like it.
- Finish the regular season with a win
- OK.
- But this game means a lot to me.
Eagles at Bears
- OK.
- Bears are favored by six.
It's the prime-time
game of Wild Card Weekend.
- Eagles at Bears.
- A touchdown. Really what we need is a touchdown.
- Almost a touchdown.
- Okay. In Chicago. Chicago D.
- In Chicago.
I don't like that you're talking a lot about the Bears.
- Cuz I don't like your Eagles.
- So much so that I'm going against them.
I'm going Bears.
- Is it just cuz you don't like my Eagles?
- No. I think the Bears are the better team.
- OK.
- I think going into Chicago—
Philly's gonna have a tough time.
- Final message to Simms?
- I hope you're going with me this week.
- I hope not. I hope not.
- So I went to Allie for a little bit of confidence—
- How did Allie do last week?
- He won. He took the Cowboys.
- Oh, good.
- But here’s the thing.
- All right.
- He’s takin’ the Bears over the Eagles.
- He’s takin’ the Bears over the Eagles?
- Bears, minus-six against the Eagles.
- Whew, gosh, six points? That’s a lot.
I didn’t realize that’s what it is.
The Bears are gonna beat your Eagles.
I just hope you know that, so deal with it, OK?
- How have you not learned about—
- Deal with the L dance, the L dance.
- About BDN and Nick Foles and how he’s—
- How have you not learned how to close the yearbook?
And that was last year, and this ain’t this year, OK?
They’re better than you.
They’re like you guys last year.
- I just wanna say, if there’s a team that I get to face—
- Right.
- It’s a team that has Mitchell Trubisky
as their quarterback in his first playoff game.
- Ohhh, OK.
- That’s what I’m saying!
- OK, fine.
- This is a team that’s goin’, “We won the division,”
and the Eagles are goin’, “We know what it
takes to get there.” There’s nothin’ in there?
- Right.
- No, you don’t value that at all?
- Well, no, there is, there’s something there.
There’s battle-tested football, certainly.
- So you would take the Bears?
- I, uh—six points, I don’t think
I would take the Bears.
I would take your Eagles to stay
within six, but you’re gonna lose.
- And I would say that if it’s within six?
- Yeah?
- Let’s talk about the other games cuz this one—
- You homer.
- We may watch the game together, and
he’s just gonna berate me the entire time.
- Right.
- But the Saturday games and the Sunday games are great.
- They’re awesome, yeah.
- Let’s go through quick. Colts at Texans.
- Whoo!
- Awful for the Texans that they have to play this team again.
- I think so, because we always talk about
the Texans that have their great D-line.
That kinda gets, you know, muted against—
- And they let up big plays.
- The great O-line of the Colts and the passing game, right.
Which, you know, the Texans pass defense is horrible.
That’s where it’s scary, but they do have Deshaun Watson—
- Yes.
- And that’s where it gets scary as well.
- But if you had to pick one right now?
- But if I had to pick, I’m goin’ Colts.
- I would too.
- Yeah.
- Seahawks at Cowboys.
- Ooh, very similar teams.
- Two teams that are obsessed with running the ball.
- Right. Obsessed. They don’t do a lot on defense.
Their whole mantra, both of those teams, is
“We’re gonna out-physical you. We’re gonna
out-hustle you. We’re not gonna mess up.”
They’re the same team.
- Dallas’ passing game defensive coordinator
used to be the defensive coordinator for the Seahawks.
- Exactly right, there’s a lot of crossover.
- I’m goin’ Cowboys.
- I am too.
Like I said, they’re the same team, really, schematically
and the way they approach the game.
I just think Dallas is the better version of that.
- And they’re at home.
- And the Seahawks are not the same team on the road.
- Precisely.
- Damn, I wanted you to take the opposite there.
Chargers-Ravens.
- Right. Ooh, this is—
- Rematch of Week 15.
- I don’t know where I’m goin’ here.
I really don’t. You know—
- 16.
- I’m going to ride the Ravens, though.
- Would you?
- Just because they’re at home, and it’s a tough place to play.
- Then I’m gonna go Chargers. Whatever you
go in that game, I’m going opposite.
- OK. It’s the game I feel—
- I have no idea.
- Exactly right. That is a coin flip to me. I don’t know where it goes.
- Because Philip Rivers, having seen the defense,
maybe he changes it up in a few weeks?
- I trust him more with the game on the
line than I do Lamar Jackson at this point.
- But yet it’s on the road and it’s cold, so those change things.
- But the Chargers are 7-1 on the road.
- Yep, I gotcha. You’re right.
- And then Eagles-Bears. The Eagles win.
- [Laughing] Bears win.
- If the Eagles win—
- Right, right.
- I can’t go down that road.
- Oh, you chicken? Ooh.
- All I’m sayin’ is, Alshon revenge game in Chicago—
- Ohh.
- Followed up by Darren Sproles’ revenge game in New Orleans.
- Oh my gosh.
- Where’s my ski mask? Where’s my ski mask?
- I know. Last year I rooted so hard for you guys
and this year I’m rooting so hard against you, it’s hilarious.
- For Simms—
- Peace out, homies. Go Bears!
- I am the L-E-F-K-O-E.
- Man.
- And fly, Eagles, fly, on the road to Chicago!
- That’s sturdy. Oh, OK.
- Thanks, bro.
- Hey, no problem.
- Enjoy the games. Holla, holla, holla.
Do you remember our coach Jeff Fisher
parachuting onto the field?
- Yeah, I remember that.
- They told us to go out on the practice
field, and we're all kinda like–
Just sittin' there, like, "what the hell
are we doing? Why are we out here early?"
And all of a sudden there was this, like,
black speck in the sky,
and it was a helicopter way up,
- Mmhmm.
- And then all of a sudden he came down!
And I just–I just, I'm still blown away by it,
I'm not even really asking you a question,
I'm just going, like, isn't that unbelievable?
- Yeah, it was definitely unbelievable.
- He did have icicles on his mustache, though.